And so the listening is sort of
the preparation for speaking.
Hi, Steve Kaufmann here and today
I want to talk a little bit about
listening, why you should listen before
you speak in language learning, and
maybe that's the lesson for life.
Make sure your mind is open and
that you're listening before you
just say whatever you want to say.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So if you follow me here, you know that
I believe in the power of input, uh, I
believe in Stephen Krashen, uh, that we
learn from meaningful messages and we
learn when we're listening to a language
and we hear things that are somehow
compelling for us, that way we learn.
And, um, of course in history,
long before we had, so input can
be listening and it can be reading.
Those are the two ways in which
the language, which we don't have
inside us, can come into our brain.
We can develop new language habits based
on this stimulus from the language that
we receive in listening or reading.
And, uh, but listening, you know,
obviously historically precedes reading,
uh, humans were communicating orally
long before we had any writing system.
People learn things by listening
to the elders or listening
to experts and so forth.
So listening is, has been
around for a long time.
So how do we listen to learn languages?
Um, in my own case, listening
is my favorite activity
because it's so easy to do.
And I think that's important.
We kind of force ourselves to do things
all the time that we find difficult.
We don't want to be pushing against,
you know, too much resistance.
Listening is something that I
can do first thing in the morning
while doing my exercises, I can
do it while preparing breakfast.
I can do it while in the car.
And I do a lot of it, probably more
than any other activity, but listening
implies some degree of understanding or
at least an attempt at understanding.
Otherwise we just hear something.
So we just hear noise.
We just hear a language and it's,
there's nothing there that we understand.
I don't think that's very
effective for language learning.
So I always make a point of listening
to something where I have access
to a transcript at a very early
stage in my language learning.
Uh, I rely on going over the transcript
because it is just noise when I start
and I go through the transcript, I
might look up words in LingQ and I
review the words and I listen again,
and I listen to the whole lesson again
and gradually sort of the fog lifts.
It's like the jigsaw puzzle as more
pieces fall into place we start to
notice some other things, but always the
listening is the easiest thing to do.
And it also triggers my reading where
I find it easier to sort of define
the words that I'm hearing if I just
rely on my listening, I, I can't
really grab what those words are.
So it's very much a combination
of listening and reading, but most
of the time is spent listening.
Now, when we listen, we aren't,
and here, I want to point out some
things that I think experienced...
at least I shouldn't say that, but in
my own case, I know that I will continue
not understanding for a long time.
It doesn't bother me.
So we listen, we don't fully understand,
but we are understanding something.
And so the language is washing over us.
We are listening.
We're not just hearing the language.
We're grabbing things here and there.
And when we listen to the second
time we notice some other things.
So, um, I combine it with listening,
but the listening itself, which is
so easy to do is also helping the
language to wash over my brain.
And I do pick out certain
things every time I listen.
Um, now the other thing about listening,
I like listening while I'm doing other
tasks, because I actually surprisingly
find it easier to concentrate...
start off by saying we can't concentrate
a hundred percent when we are listening
to anything, uh, let alone in a foreign
language where it requires a little more
concentration to, to understand what's
being said to sort of seize upon those
things that we do understand and try to
fill in some things that we don't yet
understand and guess what they mean.
So all of this stuff requires a fair
amount of concentration, but you
can't be concentrating the whole time.
If I sit down to deliberately
listen, I find it more difficult.
My mind is more likely to
wander for some reason.
On the other hand, if I'm driving, if I'm
doing the dishes, if I'm exercising, I'm
not worried about when my mind wanders.
I'm assuming that my mind is going
to wander uh, and for some reason
I'm able to better concentrate.
Obviously exercising is more
difficult, but doing the dishes I'm
able to, I'm able to concentrate.
And if it's, if it's the mini stories
where there's a lot of repetition,
I start noticing certain structures
that I didn't notice before.
If it's more advanced content in
languages that I speak say relatively
well, I'm more focused on the meaning.
I don't listen to those things so
often, but all of this has helped the
language sort of wash over my brain.
And while we do this, and especially we
combine it with reading, we are building
up our capability to speak, but the
listening especially starts certain
phrases sort of ringing in our brains.
And we get to a point where
we want to try these out.
We may use them wrong.
We may fall flat on our face, but
we build up this well of things
that we want to say in the language,
because we've been listening a lot.
And so the listening is sort of
the preparation for speaking, and
it's not only sort of the easiest
activity to do, it's very easy
to find an hour a day to listen.
15 minutes here, 20 minutes
there you put together an hour.
Uh, hopefully that triggers you
to go and read the same content if
you have access to the transcript.
So it's a very easy activity to do.
It's a fun activity.
Listening comprehension is also a
major goal in language learning so that
the, the activity becomes the goal.
Uh, not the medium is the message, but
you know, the activity of learning is the
goal itself, because if we can achieve a
high degree of listening comprehension.
We now have access to so much more in
the language that we can use to improve.
This could be simply having meaningful
conversations with people because we
understand more of what they're saying.
It's very frustrating to be in a
conversation with someone where
you struggle to say something,
and then you don't understand
what they're saying back to you.
Um, if we have good listening
comprehension, we can listen to podcasts.
We can watch a Netflix films or series.
So the listening comprehension, which
we achieved through lots of listening
is not only the main activity it
becomes the goal because you get
a sort of a multiplying effect.
Once you achieve a certain level
of listening comprehension, you can
listen to more compelling material,
which increases your ability to
understand your listening comprehension.
And it just gets you
on a sort of...some...
gives you momentum in your
language learning that will
eventually lead to better fluency.
So once you have enough of that
comprehension and you have taken advantage
of your listening comprehension to,
you know, access all of the kind of
content that's available on the internet,
listening and hopefully reading and
looking at words on LingQ or whatever,
once you are, you know, headed in
that direction the speaking will come.
And so that's why I always say, listen
before you speak, that's not to say
you can't start speaking whenever you
want, but make sure that even as you
start speaking, put a lot of emphasis
on listening because when you're,
if you're not very, you know, at an
early stage, if your comprehension
isn't very well developed and you're
struggling to say something, you're
going to be mostly focusing on
trying to say what it is you have to.
Whereas, if you're focusing enough
time on listening, you're building
up that listening comprehension and
eventually you'll end up speaking better.
So I just wanted to make that
point about listening someone
similar to the discussion I had
in French a couple of weeks ago.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.